ces jo
quoi
il
g jona
demain de matière à demain tu vas voir
demain je dépose plainte
dommage dépose plainte qu'il dépose
plainte human agressé dûment agréé c'est
toi tu me touches qui ne fument pas tu
vas voir doc ne filme pas je vais avoir
demain tu vas voir tu vas voir demain tu
laboures demain c'est quoi tu vas faire
tu vas soir va faire c'est quoi ton
frère tu préfères tu vas voir toi et ton
hubert tu vas voir tu dois savoir est
une preuve cyber way entièrement aux
cubains tu verras tu verras que m'a tout
de suite c'était un homme et raz de
marée
c'était un homme du film touchant rade
matière à donna te verra demain jean
terme en fait des gens terme en fils
mais tu vas voir
la station tu me connais pas mais tu
connais pas penses tu que je suis con
quand on regarde froide
audard tchéquie [ __ ] on a au roi en
étudier on a dû [ __ ] on a des gars
armés d'avoir également manager j'aime
avoir du plantoir y est capable de faire
ces travaux la traiter criminels dabach
nahd et regarde maintenant on va voir ça
demain on va voir ça oui devant revoir
ça tu vas voir c'est moins que votre